Aloha reject nation greg alba here and
i'm john so we're gonna watch the day
from screen junkies the honest trailers
for spider-man homecoming oh man i
haven't seen a screen junkies video in a
minute yeah it's been a while i mean i
mean a couple of instagram posted by the
hole a nice ignore situation and I made
one based off their last update as well
I'll just put it out here on YouTube
really quick I have felt since day one
of what's been revealed with in terms of
a nice ignore yes he should be fired I'm
glad he is fired I think it's very brave
of everyone who came forward and just in
terms of the masses you know not just
what happened with screen junkies a nice
ignore but in terms of like Harvey
Weinstein oh yeah all the really popular
figures coming forward anyway revealing
information has been very beneficial
it's empowering for a lot of people
while can be triggering it can be
empowering at the same time well yeah it
seems like it's opening a floodgate now
where like it doesn't stop you if you
are demonstrating this type of
misconduct it seems like someone's
actually gonna come for you yeah exactly
that's a good thing I feel a movement
and a shift happening that has been
waiting to happen for a long time but in
regards to just screen junkies alone I
feel like they should continue and he
was never my favorite and it wasn't it
was never the Andy signor show to me
yeah there are so many people who work
there there's so many people who still
contribute something that is worthwhile
and who are doing it and exactly the
finest way possible I felt like if Andy
had just left with no sexual allegations
made towards him whatsoever yeah I feel
like what I've been worried at all more
yeah more than enough people who are a
capable and beware to keep it going yeah
so as long as you can you know shiny up
that name again and get the stigma off
of yeah this takes it but you know this
video was like one of the top training
videos the other day I haven't seen it
yet
anyway I'm glad you guys are still
continuing and still being creative here
you were my spoilers in zombie yeah
since 2002 we've had six movies two
reboots and three spider-man now just
when audiences might be getting a little
sick of the franchise
Barbara swoops in to deliver a
crowd-pleasing comedy that's gonna keep
spider-man in theaters until the in Sun
burns out of the sky mattress spider-man
homecoming I'm very sure Tobey Maguire
couldn't Andrew Garfield couldn't get it
started
it's the ground swinging in a great mood
that's just a suit you're all caught up
with the MCU completely over origin
story an actor who doesn't have
premature old face and he had some
forced personal connection to Peter Pan
lose his dad all right two out of three
[Laughter]
constantly laws watch's himself on
YouTube he's got all the usual spider
skills plus a powerful new one never
facing consequences for his actions
whether he's getting away with did you
detention wrecking a cool
ranking of berries or rating his
girlfriend's entire life you can be sure
this webslinger will get off with no
more than a stern talking-to kid here
well the older I get the more I relate
to change on the Jameson be tremendous
to the entire city and birth ban now
prepare for Michael Keaton's third man
creature role as the vulture
he's a blue-collar guy who gets shafted
by Stark Industries soon and instead of
filing a lawsuit against a billionaire
clearly sorry Uncle Ben and Richard
Parker there's a new absentee dad in
town Iran he stores
Iron Man is back as the drunk rich
stepfather you'd expect him to be who
builds you a killer robot suit
activating instant kill send you into
battle at 15 then literally phone in his
parent aid until you screw up enough to
get his attention okay it's not working
out I'm gonna need you tonight really
Tony you just fought your best friend
over keeping tabs on superheroes and you
just let your pet superhero run amuck is
anyone paying attention to the timeline
anymore this is approaching x-men levels
of sloppy she sends Bishop back in time
no just his consciousness into his
younger self
so enjoy another super smash hit whoo
success was far from guaranteed with two
competing Studios fighting for control
six different screenwriters ended a
rager with just two low-budget Indies to
his name Danny finally cracked the code
on how to make the spider burst habit do
drugs chef as a buddy voice of Jennifer
Connelly you can call me Karen if you
would like Oh was that oh man yeah
Bulger or the unexpected virtue of
casting Michael yeah in the movie
ravioli berry pixie jingoro
hey there Martin Starr now not not
raishin sidekick and he's in an elevator
shaft I can't catch a break with that
Oh Beetlejuice Beetlejuice till darkness
falls across the way all right the
midnight hour is close at hand I am
David pumpkins any questions Halloween
the night he came home well I'm glad
these guys are back doing what they do
best good old honest tease I did not
think about how the whole personal
connection thing with the villain oh
yeah it was such a well done reveal yes
this time they surprised you with it
it's dead yeah the most surprising like
plot turns of one of these movies has
given me in a while I was yeah [ __ ] not
expecting that that who's a really great
twist that I'd even think that the whole
personal connection to the Peter some
great jokes in here man there's some
pretty good joke he's now make a
different way to make him relate is true
Tom Holland does have that face it's not
gonna get too old fast he could be a
high school kid for a long time
we can make so many movies where Peters
in high school to the point that you're
like how does he not graduating yeah I
like that point to about like nobody
disciplines Peter Parker for anything he
was gonna do what he wants yeah he feels
guilty though long as Peter feels the
weight of the shoulders long as world
weighted the shoulders on the shoulders
against his world he feels the weight of
the world on his shoulders that's his
way of suffering
that's his consequences way of making up
for lost discipline yeah is the guilt
and the guilt can outweigh so much more
than anyone actually lecturing you
oh yeah I mean guilt is the ultimate
punishment Tony gives him consequences
out damn spot
yeah he does isn't he yeah Tony Tony
takes away the suit once and what kind
of lectures the kid nobody at regular
school does this no no no he can get
away with pretty much anything had that
bit though about how he doesn't sue
Stark Industries yeah like he would have
such an easy case they're like this is
not appropriate a B you're taking
business oh hey yeah I think start
interested have been glad to pay him off
if it was really about the keeping the
money around and check and stuff like
that because he was talking about being
a provider he probably could have gotten
a lot more out of it and wouldn't have
had to risk his life and the safety of
his family yeah because he's a dad we
like him yeah yeah exactly because he's
dead we understand why he did this yeah
except he could have probably got you
know good amount of money for himself
and his crew from doing it and I like
the way autos trailers set it up with
instead he'll build a vulture mechanical
[Laughter]
there's no actual I mean it's it's an
efficient suit to help me get in and out
of pulling off robberies and whatever
but it's also conspicuous yeah yeah I
can see why it's but it is a little
left-field in terms of if you had no
comic book knowledge or any expectation
of the vulture is like why would you go
for that exact she was hilarious dude
we're talking a lot about spider-man
homecoming this year I know I know it
seems like they didn't really have much
too many holes to poke no no not at all
I mean we'd do like an hour-long spoiler
review but the the film was great to me
yeah
this is one of the films I enjoyed most
this summer I would say it's one of my
top 5 favorite films this year actually
no I might put it up there I would say
like we go the mommy
definitely the mummy definitely what
else American assassin American assassin
air leather face leather face and then
Wonder Woman alright guys thanks for
tuning in you can subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell and you can follow us on social
media check us out on the stardust app
download and follow us at the real
rejects where we post 30-second
reactions for any film TV show or
trailer yeah